[Music]
Hello, how are you, andrés gonzález,
with your brief informative for today, Monday
, September 27, several people were
hospitalized after an accident
near charleston and lahm. This morning the
injuries are serious and the
metro investigative team is
evaluating this incident  After
reporting more than 100 fatalities
in traffic accidents
so far this year, 102 deaths are reported
compared to 101 for all of
2020. On Saturday, a couple from
Massachusetts died in a
Rouyanian raid accident, detectives say
they  they lost control of the vehicle
and collided so far that is all the
information that the authorities gave
also on Saturday a high
school student was understood to have died
after being hit by a car on the
center and near traffic supposedly
the minor was not crossing properly and was
hit by police said the
driver remained on the scene
and into her  xication was not a factor in this
incident
in investor an agreement was reached to
buy the cosmopolitan for more than 1000
million dollars in good he said that it is
a 30 year lease with options
to renew the contract every 10 and now
we turn to the weather forecast
temperatures will be warm during the
day however it will feel cool
starting in the morning we will reach 90
degrees by this afternoon but the
winds coming from the west will return nice
day cheers andrés gonzález and that was
about the news now in
spanish
[Music  ]